not trust me all right I was in Orlando
ran in a tiger woods okay
like you guys are gonna stand you want
to bring the inner bit I'm gonna bit
that way you know where you rotate okay
bring that rotation around you know and
that was before you got himself involved
in this mess
yeah I've been able to make it out to
the links in a while my little cousins
gonna this and wanna keep your head all
the way up straight ahead of all off you
dropped too far you know you had a
couple two minutes you scream three
times that efforts for bringing box
cutters on I can't get in my damn
luggage my wife puts too many locks on
the absolutely
hey see on the green ass boys
what the hell is this shut up and sign
oh man oh yeah it's for all my buddies I
got shot go Scott Baio let's go Frankie
moon yes everybody's on like chill
everybody some pressure on me but not
lose it oh I don't like in too many
YouTube videos
you being child being ridiculous right
now you're being immature really that
was mature in high school I had a car go
be right yeah so we're gonna go to
school let's go bags I call them they're
the mayor on the phone okay I'll make a
call today
you run this up to the grade let me
cheat look I love you so much but why I
got three putters in my belts don't buy
these kinds of bags that don't supply
bags with a strap I have to carry this
under my arm it's heaviest son I bought
it with a threat but it's a Gucci strap
and I don't trust you with it oh I'm
pissed off now
you didn't piss me off now hey guys
still get into Dartmouth you think stay
behind me
he's self destruct you need to watch
that fan mr. Bern I found my kid eat a
whole box of Bisquick in a no milk or
nothing just went to town on the
Bisquick holy wait we got Osama
you see a schooler yeah high school nice
yeah my daughter goes i school maybe
I'll stop I say what so next time I'm
there
that was four I counted 27 stroke man
you are so full of sand bugs in there
there's bugs i target the bugs out looks
like it's clean now I'm trying to get
the bugs out try to put your little
pecker in there no you're not my hair a
pallet actually leave
okay fellas Gary 197 love my boys I love
my boys what a score today
I'm okay with me today yes